there are Avengers and Game spoilers in
this video I feel like I don't really
have to say that anymore but I'm gonna
do it anyway okay let's go Tom Holland
is an amazing spider-man great dancer
wonderful guy but let's be real he's the
mayor of spoiler city there are endless
compilation videos about it so knowing
this the Avengers end game directors
actually lied to Tom about Tony Stark's
sad sad sad funeral scene this is how
bad it is for me
I was told it was a wedding real quick
another super interesting tidbit about
that scene Cobie Smulders said it was
shot before black panther came out over
a year ago okay back to Tom spoiling
this is a pretty well-known fact so I
actually asked the Russo brothers about
this during an interview for infinity
war last year how do you feel that Tom
Hollands spent the entire press tour
spoiling aspects of the movie over what
are you gonna do it's sort of he's the
nicest guy in the world so you know ever
be punitive towards a towards Tom
Holland people made like super cuts of
it as my favorite thing is it like 15
minutes five Tom starring in spider-man
far from home out in July which picks up
right after the events of Avengers and
game right after that funeral scene so
the trailer came with a disclaimer given
by none other than Tom Holland himself
you haven't seen Avengers end game yet
stop watching because there's some
serious spoilers about to come up and of
all people I gave this point yeah they
also addressed the biggest question I
had after endgame because so the snap
brings you right back to where you were
right but it's five years later so by
that logic half of the students at his
high school would have been gone like
off to college right they would be older
so why are they all back in high school
why did everyone stop going to school or
half the students five years older like
what what I have so many questions which
is a great time to plug my Avengers and
game unanswered questions video it's
here on ET be sure to subscribe to all
things et I'm Ash Carlson if you want to
chat bye bye